annemin dediği gibi aya gitmedi
ondan çok Daha uzağa gittin
çünkü
iki yer arasındaki en uzak mesafe
zamanıdır
ben oradayım
Az önceki replikler bana değil sizi Az
sonra tanıştıracağım Tom dindiyor'a ait
Umarım etkinlik hepiniz için keyifli
geçiyordur Çünkü biraz sonra keyfi çok
da yerinde olmayan bir aileden bir evden
bahsedeceğim
ve konuşmanın sonuna doğru da sizinle
birisini tanıştırmak istiyorum ama ondan
önce bahsedeceğim birkaç şey var
dışardayken bir sokakta yürürken bir
Pencereden bir evin içine baktığınızda
çok kısıtlı Bir Görüş olmanız vardır
belki evin içindeki birkaç dakika Koru
belki
elimdeki birkaç insanın belki açık bir
televizyonu Eğer akşamsa evin içine
süzülen ışığı görebilirsiniz ama çok
küçük ipuçlarıdır Bunlar Örneğin bir
mutfak gördüğümüzü Hayal edelim pencere
pencerenin İçinden bir buzdolabı
üstlerinde rengarenk magnetler Belki bu
evde yaşayanların gezdiği yerlerden
satın alta magnetler ve buzdolabına
yapıştırmışlar Belki bir ailedir ya da
bir mutfak tezgahı düşünelim çok kirli
olduğunu düşünüyorum Bir bekar evi
olabilir ya da
çok trajik bir şekilde ayrılmış bir
çiftin bir haftalık bir fotoğrafı ya da
bu kadar traş olup olmaya da gerek yok
bir çocuğun ailesi bir hafta sonra
tatile gitmiştir
ama
şunu Bir açıklık getirmek istiyorum
dışarıdan baktığımızda bir ev hakkında;
elde
edip bitkilerin en fazla bu kadardır
Yani biz en fazla o evde birisini
yaşadığını Belki çok küçük hareketli
dinlemek yerine Belki de evin boş olup
olmadığını nereden biliyoruz
en fazla bu kadar
aynı şey insanlar için de geçerli
dışkıya aynı şekilde dışarıdan
baktığımızda
Evet belki sosyopatlık durumu hakkında
belki ayet olduğu bir topluluk varsa
bunları öğrenebiliyoruz Ama bu da aynı
şekilde sınırlı
konuya dönecek olursam evler
bu evlerin içlerine girmeden yani ancak
birisinin Bizi misafir etmesi gerekiyor
bu evrenin içine almayı bilmemiz için
bizim evlerimizin içine almayı bilmemiz
için
Ama bu maalesef mümkün değil birinin
gelip anlatması gerekiyor ama sadece
didaktik anlatıyla da olmaz Böyle daha
coşkul ve anlatım gerekli değil mi hatta
birisi karşınızda canlandırsa bunu
bunu da gerçekçi bir yolda ne yapsam
bunu da sahne taşıdığımızda tiyatro
oluyorum
doğduğu günde Bugün de tiyatronun hizmet
ettiği asıl amaçlı
bahsettiğim bir karakter vardı ya o
aslında bir tiyatro oynadılar prensesi
bir kokusal karakter ama korkusal
denilime de bakmayın
ama onunla mutlaka karşılaşırsınızdır
Belki
babanızdır belki her Günsel anlaştığınız
birisidir belki bilmiyorum Buraya
gelirken kavga ettiniz birisi
dir Tom ve fiyat bir evde yaşıyor ve
şimdi size bu evin içine girmeye davet
ediyorum
oyunun konusu kısaca şöyle 1900'lerin
1930'ların sonunda Amerika'da geçiyor Ve
o dönemde çok ağır bir ekonomik Buhran
var
ve bu ailenin en büyük çatışmasını
yaratan şey Baba evi terk etmiş
Tabii ki de Geleneksel aile tiplerinden
bahsedecek olursak
Baba evi terk ettiği anda ne kadar çok
umuma oluşuyor yani gelirken getirecek
çocuklar küçük mü çocuklar kendine
bakabilecek yeterliliklerine ya da
anneme çalışacak Yani
gelirlerinizi nasıl sağlanacak Bunlar
nasıl çözülecek
[Müzik]
evimiz de yani
Oyunda 3 Ana karakter var Birincisi anne
alanda
Amanda Aslında
düşündüğünüzde oyunun biraz birazcık
izlediğimizde anne profiline
inanılmaz güzel bir kadınmış yani hatta
güzelliği değil sadece Olay birazcık da
Çizmeli bir kadınmış yani hatta
çocukların sürekli şu anasını anlatır
bir gün bulunmamda tam 17 görüşüp beni
görmeye gelmişlerdi çoğu zaman oturacak
yer bile bulamazdık onları
tekrar başında Pervane olurlar
dı
olan bir kadın da ailemin çekilmesiyle
Daha sonrasında Hocanın evi terk etmesi
babanın evi terk etmesiyle hayatıma çok
daha dirayette yapıyor çok daha Dominant
bir karakter haline geliyor Amanda
benzetiyorum o da ağaçta
ama onda mutluluğu değildir ve
çoğu zaman insanlara bir şeyler söyler
Aslında mutlu olmadığını söylüyorlar ama
çok farklı şekilde ve özellikle Tom'a
bunu sürekli yansıtıyor Örneğin ton
Amanda çok bencil olduğunu düşünüyor
onun annesinin onu anlamadığını
düşünüyor
belki birazcık tanıdık gelmiş de
olabilir
ancak karakteriniz ise oyundaki en
kırılgan karakterli evde işte evrenlerce
hiç çıkmaz Hatta oyun adına doğru adam
alır
oyuna küçük sırtça cam oyuncaklarında
ve Laura'nın Topal oluyor olması
oyunun üstüne bir kara bulut gibi
çökmüştür çünkü
sonra
öyle bir
özgüvensizlik içerisine giriyor ki;
Okula gidemiyor okula gitse başka bir
şey yapamıyor gibi geliyor O kadar
sıkışmış
bir şey daha sonrasında
ana karakterimiz ton var
oyunun konuşmam gerekirse Tom
Bu oyun bu oyunda hayali olan tek kişi
hayalleri hala getirmemişler oyunun
polis ise çok aslında
böyle sanatta çok ilgisi olan bir
karakterdir ayakkabı fabrikasının
çalışmasına rağmen ayak kapağı
kutularının kapağına Çin yazıyor
ve her akşam Sinemaya gidiyordum ama
çalıştığı yer bahsettiğim gibi bir
ayakkabı fabrikası
ve bunu sadece evi geçirebilmek için
yapıyor
Aslında bıraksalar Belki çok daha farklı
şeyler yapmak istey
ecek eve bağlayan tek şey yani babası
gibi evi terk etmekten alıkoyan tek şey
Flora
ben de oraya da tohumu şeye benzettim
Hani sokakta yürürken yavru kediler
gördüyseniz ya da hava soğuksa
birbirlerinin yanaşırlar
o kokularından
ısınmaya çalışırlar ama hala
titriyorlardır ama birbirlerine
sahiptirler
Burada da denemek istediğim bir yer var
benim için kişisel anlamda da çok önemli
Hani geçen hafta ya da geçen gün
bu sabah bilmiyorum bir yer önce size
böyle çok ters yapmış birisi vardı ya
böyle belki selamınıza cevap vermedi Ya
da belki trafikte çok sağlam önünüze
kırdı çok terbiyesizce
bu kişi Tom da olabilir
Belki de oydu
bu kişi
aman da olabilir
hikayelerini bildiğiniz üzere
durduğumuz taraf nasıl değişiyor
ya belki ton o yaş ayakkabı
fabrikasından çıkmıştı ve Eve bir an
önce varmak istiyordu ayaktan uzatmak
istiyordu
ama biliyor ki evde de huzur yok akşam
sinemaya çıkıyor Her akşamdan evde
barınamadığı için
en sonunda önünüze
şey çok hoşuma gidiyor özellikle tiyatro
düzleminde
kimsenin hikayesi diğerinden daha
değerli olmuyor
oyuna geri dönecek olursam
oyun bu erkeğin de
çok huzursuz kavgada havasından oyunun
sonuna kadar çok başarılı bir şekilde
devam ettiriyor Hatta devam ettirmekle
kalmayıp
çok günden günlere saniyeden saniye bu
gergin sıkışır kanlarını Elbette
Patlamaya giden yolculuğunu Biz seyir
halinde istiyoruz
en sonunda annesiyle Tom'u çok ağır çok
büyük bir kavga ederler ve ton
artık kapanmayacak yaralar açmışlar
aynısından aynı şekilde aynısı da onda
ve
söylemeyecek sözler
dönünmeyecek yollara girmişler artık
Hani ton eşyaları kapıya yönlüdür
Annesi der ki Nereye gidiyorsun
Tom der yine sinemaya
annesi gözlerinin içine bakıp der ki
git
istiyorsan aya git sen bence sen o
bencilliğin Ne o Topal Kız kardeşin Sen
beni boş ver
Sen istiyorsan aya git der
ve Tom kapıyı açar
dışarı çıkar
ama o girdiği kapıdan Bir daha içeri
geri girmez
tam oyunun sonunda evi terk eder
ve en sonunda da
seyirciyle şurada paylaşır
[Müzik]
annemin dediği gibi Ay'a Gitme
onlar çok daha Uzağa gittim Çünkü iki
yer arasındaki en uzak mesafe zaman
ben oradayım
[Müzik]
bir ayakkabı kutusunun kapağını şiir
yazdığım için işten atıldım
Ondan sonra terk ettim sayılırsa Bir
daha geri dönmedim
Ondan sonra adımların beni hep babamın
yolundan götürdü
[Müzik]
sanki boşluk dedim ve var olmayan bir
şeyler yapıyordum
yani kalmadı
şehirler sanki
ayaklarımın altındaki Kuru yapraklar
[Müzik]
bir zamanlar parlak renkleri falan ama
laftır
[Müzik]
bir yerlerde durabilirdin ama
Hiç Fark ettirmeden takip etti beni hiç
ummadığım anlarda yakaladı
[Müzik]
belki tanıdıklığımızı inandırıyordu
Belki bir Sırça parçasıydı
Belki de
yabancı bir şekilde kendime tanımadığım
arkadaşlar durmadan evvel bu
Daha sonrasında bir sokaktan geçiyorum
orada bir vitrin görüyorum
rengarenk çok gıcık oluyorum o
rengarenk saçacağım parfüm şişeleri var
hepsi hepsi sanki gökkuşunun
gökkuşağının renklerinden kopmuş da
oraya düşmüş gibi
[Müzik]
onu da aklıma öyle geliyor
gözlerinin içine bakıyorum
[Müzik]
onu terk ettiğimi söyleyemiyorum
seni terk etmek denedim ama
sanımdan çok daha fazla sadıkmışım sana
sonra bir paketten hepsi sigara
yakıyorum caddeye geçiyorum bir bara
oturuyorum
en yakındaki bahçede sokakta başlıyorum
ama
[Müzik]
Bunlar sonucunda ortalıkta yabancılar
falan kalmıyor
[Müzik]
bu dünyaya artık mumlar değil
Şimşekler haline getiriyor
Sen de söndürme
Hoşça kal
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
az önce
burada çok güzel bir şey oldu
az önce bir eve daha girdik
ve birisiyle daha gerçekten tanıştık
dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]